bonsoir alexis foulard merci d'être avec
nous alors clore la séquence sur les
retraites un petit peu l'ambition d'
emmanuel macron même s'ils ne se
prononce pas encore clairement sur le
sujet quand on voit que même la cdt
menacent de faire grève à la rentrée on
se dit que cette affaire risque de
mettre du monde dans la rue évidemment
elle a déjà mis beaucoup de monde dans
la rue alors de la première mouture il a
fallu utiliser le 49-3 rappelez-vous le
premier conseil sanitaire a été réservé
et finalement au 49 3 pour faire passer
cette réforme des retraites au forceps
avec tous ces français tous les
partenaires sociaux dans la rue vent
debout contre cette réforme
rien n'a changé à la crise sanitaire est
passée par là c'est encore pire parce
que on se demande pourquoi vouloir à
tout prix remettre cette réforme sur le
tapis alors qu' il y à bien d'autres
choses à faire notamment aller chercher
la reprise économique
ce que dit bruno le maire cherchait ses
5 % de croissance faire en sorte
d'éviter l'entrée dans la précarité de
centaines de milliers de français
avec la réforme de l'assurance chômage
ce qui là encore n'est pas forcément le
bon moment c'est ce qu'a dit le conseil
d'état d'ailleurs et on al impression qu
emmanuel macron lui swing feuille de
route qui n'est pas du tout celle du
peuple ou même des partenaires sociaux
et qui est simplement de dire je dois
faire ces réformes parce que sans ça je
serai sanctionné alors pas par forcément
les urnes puisque visiblement ça n'a pas
l'air de l'inquiéter mais peut-être par
l'union européenne qui demande des
réformes structurelles pour avoir ces
aides à la relance ce plan de quelques
milliards dead qui est conditionnée aux
réformes structurelles
alors aujourd'hui on se demande pourquoi
vouloir à tout prix remettre cette
réforme sur le tapis alors que le diable
comme je le disais d'autres sujets
importants et je pense que là emmanuel
macron pense qu'il est capable de faire
passer tout et n'importe quoi dans ces
derniers mois en disant qu'il est
heureuse
il ne doit pas porter le flanc la
critique en fait parce qu'il s'est vendu
comme ce grand président réformateur qui
changerait la france enkysté dans la
possibilité des réformes et lui son but
c'était de casser les corps
intermédiaires les corps d'état il l'a
fait avec la réforme de l'ena et donc
s'ils arrêtent en cours de route il
pourrait être bien sûr attaqué par un
candidat de droite que vous aviez
bertrand
ou n'importe quel qui sortira d'une
primaire l air ou autres qui dira que ce
président a encore menti et a été
incapable de réformer le pays
donc je crois que une d un des objectifs
est évidemment de merrimack rond c'est
cet objectif là justement alexis j'y
venais 1
quoi qu'il en soit quoi qu'il en coûte
on a l'impression que emmanuel macron ce
piège lui même soit il ne fait rien il
sera accusé de ne rien faire et de ne
pas avoir tenu ses promesses soit il
fait effectivement avec le risque social
et peut-être la perte d'une élection
derrière évidemment on a l'impression
que pour lui c'est perdant-perdant ou
alors c'est un énième coup de poker
comme on l'a vu et mais les coups de
poker tout au long de ce quinquennat
aujourd'hui ne pas réformer et ne pas
aller au bout un de ses promesses comme
il l'avait fait ce serait évidemment
prêter le flanc à la critique d'un
président incapable encore un roi
fainéant il y en a eu beaucoup
et donc un candidat de droite arrivera
en disant allez enfin nous allons la
faire cette réforme et ce ne sera pas un
modèle macron qui la fera et puis il ya
aussi la manière stratégique de faire
des macarons qui dit écoutez peut-être
que je la remets aujourd'hui sur la
table pour que nos émotions pendant des
mois les moins qu il nous reste dans mon
mandat et nous ferons cette réforme si
je suis réélu et là à ce moment là il
serait capable de couper l'herbe sous le
pied d'un candidat de droite en faisant
voter pour moins comme ça cette réforme
sera fait avec le temps de la
concertation nécessaire et l'état de la
relance on verra à ce moment-là en 2022
quel sera l'état de l'économie française
donc dans tous les cas ça peut être un
coup de poker qui serait gagnant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que tous les
grands partis sont divisés n'ont pas
encore de champion avérée de programmes
clairs aurait pas normal qu'on lui peut
dérouler ce programme clair finir les
réformes continuent et le mandat qui lui
a été donné même si ce n'est pas un
mandat a grandement majoritaire à il
était très mal élu en 2017 il pourrait
être très mal élu en 2022 et continuer
ce travail de réforme du pays alors que
d'autres voudraient le faire à sa place
donc c'est peut-être une façon aussi de
continuer en disant que je dois faire
des choses difficiles
nous verrons si jamais la contestation
est trop lourde alors il laissera
peut-être sa place à quelqu'un comme
edouard philippe ou un autre qui prendra
le flambeau de ce qu'il restera de la
république en marche un parti bien mal
en point alors à 12 mois - 12 - se
retrouve des présidentielles finalement
lexical président réussi à faire ce type
de réforme d'importance
on est vraiment à moins de 12 moins on
est la même à dix mois huit mois
personne aucun président ne peut
réformer dans ce temps là d'autant plus
que haendel macron va être le président
qui va hériter de la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne du
conseil européen à partir de janvier
donc là l'agenda sera totalement
européens ce qui lui permettra de
dérouler sa communication pro européenne
avec ses partenaires du groupe du groupe
renaissance aux personnes parlement
européen donc il lui reste en réalité
même pas six mois la moitié d'une année
alors même que les ministères vont être
empêtré dans des difficultés qu'elle
soit sociale avec en fonction de la
crise de la contestation de la hauteur
de la contestation une relance
économique qui pourrait tarder à arriver
des risques sur la relance des risques
aussi de shaikh nombreuses donc de
contestation là on est vraiment dans ce
volontarisme typique des malades macron
qui veut toujours dire je vais le faire
je dois être en marche parce que si je
m'arrête alors c'est la fin de tout
puisque la promesse d'en marche celle de
tout le temps être en mouvement peu
importe où on va même si c'est dans le
mur
il faut y aller donc il va y aller et il
verra et à chaque fois il a su
improviser regarder la crise des gilets
jaunes
il a volé la parole des gilets jaunes
qui demandait un grand débat citoyen il
a fait ce grand débat où il a monopolisé
la parole
donc il pourrait tout à fait utiliser
encore des des techniques de
communication comme il a su le faire
pour lancer cette réforme des retraites
qui n'en sera pas une
et puis dérouler son programme avec la
présidence de l'ue européenne à partir
de janvier
mais c'est sûr que dans les ministères
dès à présent tout le monde qui est
encore dans les cabinets ministériels
sont là pour faire campagne sans doute
pour la réélection de balmain compte du
moment qu'il va se présenter à sa
réélection